Transcription: Marcos Orcastegui
Relecteur: eric vautier
Sur l’île de Maré,
en Nouvelle-Calédonie,
une petite tribu.
Elle s’appelle Roh.
C’est là que j’ai passé
une partie de mon enfance,
que j’ai appris à faire les chants,
que j’ai joué avec mes cousins, mes amis.
C’est mon berceau, mon lien à la terre.
Je suis Kanak.
(Applaudissements)
Mais en novembre 2020,
la violence s’écrase sur elle.
La déflagration est terrible.
120 personnes sont chassées,
déracinées de leurs propres terres.
Elles sont contraintes de fuir.
Elles sont mises dehors.
Poussées
au-delà des frontières de l’île.
Mais qui les chasse ?
Le feu, la violence, les menaces ?
Les cases sont détruites, brûlées.
Les bateaux sont calcinés.
Des tombes profanées.
Des cendres...
partout.
Je connais les auteurs.
Ce sont mes cousins
de la même tribu et des tribus voisines,
devenus
les bras armés de la terreur.
Les raisons de ces actes
sont multiples et complexes,
saupoudrées d’ego, assoiffées de pouvoir.
Désaccords et vieilles querelles
de famille sur fond de jalousie.
Ce 2 novembre restera
une date sombre de notre histoire
gravée à jamais
dans la tête des si Nengonés,
les habitants de Maré.
Je suis Kanak.
Je pense à ceux qui fuient toute forme
de violence et de persécution.
Je pense à tous ces expulsés
du monde entier,
dispersés sur les routes et sur les mers
en quête d’une terre d’accueil
et d’un refuge,
là où ils pourront, peut-être,
se reconstruire.
(Piano)
Bien loin de la Méditerranée cette fois,
c’est ma propre famille
que je vois sur les écrans.
Les exilés, je connais leurs visages
et l’émotion me prend aux tripes.
Personne n’a été tué.
C'est un miracle.
Mais pour les victimes,
le déracinement est une torture.
Vivre entre quatre murs
dans des logements sociaux
à Nouméa, la capitale,
c’est leur nouvel horizon.
Bien sûr que nous sommes chanceux.
Un toit sur notre tête et la solidarité
qui s’organise sont un réconfort immense.
Mais rien.
Rien ne nous préparait à cela.
Nous n'étions pas en guerre.
Sur l’île,
notre passé a été rayé.
Le padoku, la chefferie,
a pris le contrôle du village.
Sa milice rôde.
Les maisons sont barricadées de pierres.
La parole sacrée de nos ancêtres,
régie par les droits de la coutume,
bafouée.
Bafouée.
Ma mère est une enfant adoptée.
Elle a quitté l’île de Tiga
pour celle de Maré.
Dans ce nouveau monde,
loin de sa famille de sang,
elle grandira.
Adulte,
on lui imposera un mariage forcé.
Malheureuse, et après bien des années,
elle s’en libérera
difficilement.
Ma mère décide de retourner
sur les lieux du drame.
C’est le monde à l’envers
qui s’ouvre devant ses yeux.
On l’oblige à faire
une coutume de pardon.
Elle s'exécute la boule au ventre.
Elle se contraint au silence.
Elle n'aura même pas la possibilité
de revoir sa maison.
À peine arrivée,
elle est poussée dehors
à nouveau.
Le geste coutumier n’existe plus.
Ténèbres.
Seule,
et désormais, sans terre.
C’est l’incompréhension, la colère
et l’indignation qui me submergent.
Le lien à la terre
est l’un des fondamentaux
de la civilisation kanak.
La terre est sacrée,
inaliénable, incontestable.
Elle me définit.
Elle dit mon clan.
Elle dit mon identité.
Alors ?
Nous sommes devenus des étrangers
dans notre propre pays ?
Oui.
Mon passé se comprime.
Un livre se ferme.
Je suis Kanak.
(Saxophone)
(Applaudissements)